trou d'eau à la saline c'est le spots de
kitesurf de la réunion un espace en
plein lagon dédié à cette pratique sur
autorisation préfectorale depuis 2007 à
l'origine de cette autorisation un homme
sébastien coupy c'est lui qui négocie à
l'époque avec les autorités pour la
reconnaissance du kite à la réunion à
une époque où la création de la réserve
marine menace sérieusement la pratique
de ce sport dans le lagon
on n'est pas les premiers utilisateurs
de cet endroit là il y avait avant nous
des nageurs et
et puis avec l'explosion de l'activité
kite il a bien fallu trouver une
solution on a été aidé par la mairie de
saint paul qui nous a dédié un espace
réservé à la pratique du kite et de la
planche à voile
un
lagon qui se prêtent à l'activité
kitesurf et planche à voile parce qu'il
est situé
sur une cote qui est vantée
l'hiver en fête quand les alizés rentrer
sur la réunion on a la chance de pouvoir
naviguer sur le lagon de la saline
depuis chaque hiver austral en saison
des alizés les kite investissent trou
d'eau à la recherche de toujours plus de
vitesse et de sauts
tech data
la particularité du spot c'est que on a
un endroit qui est suffisamment grand
pour pouvoir décoller les voiles démêler
les lignes et se mettre à l'eau en toute
sécurité la nominée aux reins du
kitesurf c'est avant tout les obstacles
donc quand il ya des arbres des maisons
c'est ça devient un peu critique et sur
le spot de petits trous d'eau en fait on
a suffisamment de place pour pouvoir
décoller les voiles et les poser
tranquillement
venu tout droit du parapente il est
ancien champion de la réunion sébastien
coupy enseigne le kite depuis l'an 2000
et en assure la défense et la promotion
c'est aussi lui l'homme de l'exploit
sportif 2010 cette année-là il réalise
une première la traversée maurice
réunion en kitesurf un défi relevé en
7h15 pour 170 km il aura fallu pour cela
attendre que le matériel évolue pour lui
permettre cet exploit
alors le kitesurf en fait c'est le c'est
le fruit de l'imagination de deux
bretons et au départ ont inventé un
cerf-volant de traction pour pallier à
un démâtage
au démâtage d'un voilier par exemple
pour faire avancer le voilier ils ont
mis au point un cerf-volant qui
pouvaient redécollé une fois qu'il était
tombé dans l'eau
bon ça a été essayé ce cerf-volant de
traction sur des pédalos sur des petits
catamarans etc et puis à manu bertin
jours qui s'est dit tiens mais je vais
essayer en surf et la pratique du
kitesurf et a explosé pas tout de suite
parce que c'était quand même pour les
pour une élite on va dire fallait être
quand même très adroit parce que les
voiles n'avait pas de 10 power c'est à
dire qu'elle une fois qu'elle était en
l'air elle tiré de façon très violente
en permanence aujourd'hui le matériel a
tellement aime bien évoluer dans le sens
de la sécurité et en même temps
au niveau de la
planée dévoile que ça devient très
accessible et tout le monde absolument
tout le monde peut pratiquer le kitesurf
est une activité qui est très accessible
m
on est finalement debout sur une planche
à grande vitesse sur l'eau et autour de
nous on n'a absolument rien on a une
voile qui est quand même assez loin à 30
mètres devant nous assez haut et tout
autour il ya vraiment l'impression qu'on
avance qui a une force quelque part qui
nous tire et que nous sort de l'eau et
c'est vraiment ses sensations qui
qui plaît à aux débutants dès qu'ils
arrivent à sortir de l'eau à se faire
tirer sur ne serait ce que dit m c'est
c'la s'est tout de suite une grande joie
lipow
moment